elle m'emmène aux toilettes elle me met
sur les toilettes elle m'enferme elle
reste devant la porte et elle fait et
elle dit bah écoute le temps que moi
j'aurais pas décidé que tu sois les
toilettes tu resteras dans les toilettes
Jean ça a été une personne qui était au
départ introverti avant d'être ici a été
dans une école publique elle a fait tout
son primaire là-bas et c'est là où on
s'est aperçu qu'il y avait des soucis à
chaque fois qu'elle rentrait de l'école
elle pleurait on se demandait pourquoi
elle pleurait elle avait pas d'amis elle
jouait toujours toute seule arriver en
CE2 Jeanne revient toujours et quand
elle revenait à la maison avait toujours
envie de faire pipi toujours toujours et
puis un jour on s'est interrogé tout ça
et puis on s'est dit pourquoi tu vas pas
aux toilettes aller à l'école et quand
on est arrivé quand on est venu à savoir
le pourquoi assez bah parce que quand je
vais aux toilettes il y a une jeune
fille qui m'oblige à rester dans les
toilettes on en est venu à le découvrir
tout à fait par hasard finalement on
essaie toujours de relativiser en disant
escale nous raconte la vérité est-ce que
c'est vrai on creusant un petit peu on
se rend bien compte que finalement ça
peut être que plausible je veux dire à
nous raconter des détails en disant
qu'au départ au départ c'était
simplement une forme de jeu voilà et que
plus ça allait plus les jours passés et
plus elle était enfermée longtemps dans
les toilettes on regroupe des éléments
on se dit bah ouais mais enfin bon
c'est vrai que elle a du mal à la même
en CE2 elle avait du mal à l'école elle
traîner voilà
elle a pas d'amis elle est toute seule
elle joue toute seule dans la cour au
courcovis nous accueillons dans les
inscriptions chaque année à peu près un
élève sur trois ayant subi du
harcèlement certains élèves sont arrivés
chez nous après avoir subi un
harcèlement accompagner violence
physique je sais qu'il y a un papa qui a
été dans l'obligation de filmer son
enfant dans la cour qui se faisait taper
parce que l'école n'entendait rien on a
des cas des cas compliqués des cas
vraiment où la famille était démuni face
à harcèlement le niveau scolaire ça peut
jouer on a un élève de CO2 qui avait des
gros gros problèmes de lecture dès que
la maîtresse l'interroger les autres
rigolent des choses comme ça le fait
aussi d'avoir de la répartie de savoir
parler ça peut aussi être une cause de
harcèlement d'être bon sport bon en foot
à la récré ceux qui n'aiment pas le foot
ceux qui n'aiment pas les choses à la
mode ceux qui sont pas copains avec les
élèves à la mode d'être à la mode tout
aucune scolarité ne peut être
performante dans ces conditions et puis
là on parle pas de niveau scolaire on
parle d'estime de soi on parle de
l'actualité écrit en fait dessus ça peut
être dangereux physiquement les enfants
le suicide fait partie de l'équation on
a eu des élèves qui se confiés sur ces
sur ces pensées un peu suicidaires c'est
très très rare on essaye bien sûr de
comprendre surtout on fait parler
l'enfant qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
combien y a-t-il d'élèves est-ce que
c'est toute la classe est-ce qu'ils
avaient quand même des amis dans l'école
est-ce que est-ce que de la violence
physique est-ce que c'était juste de la
violence morale est-ce que est-ce que
c'était que à l'école ou est-ce que
c'était aussi sur les réseaux est-ce que
etc etc on a été voir un petit peu les
gens qui gérait le périscolaire après on
a été voir aussi la direction de l'école
la réponse de des gens qui gérait les
périscolaires etc bah oui mais enfin
c'est un jeu c'est pas grave puis après
quand on voyait quand il voyait que on
insistait et puis que on s'interrogeait
et ben la réponse était de se dire bah
oui mais enfin vous savez on est deux on
est trois j'ai x élève à gérer moi je
peux pas mettre une personne devant de
la porte des toilettes ou tout le temps
en gros débrouillez-vous quoi
aujourd'hui un directeur qui voudrait
exclure un élève qui a fait des
violences qui a été qui a été violent
qui a fait du harcèlement etc c'est la
croix et la bannière pour lui et du coup
on peut laisser en place des systèmes de
violence de harcèlement qui pourrait
être coupé net vous voyez je pense qu'il
faut vraiment mettre en place des
systèmes de régulièrement mais au niveau
de la classe pas au niveau de la nation
vous voyez un élève ça le dépasse trop
quel a été le problème cette semaine il
y a-t-il eu des problèmes comment
peut-on les régler quelque chose de de
régulier et à l'échelle de l'enfant une
heure de sensibilisation où on est les
900 élèves du bahut dans une grande
salle moi j'y crois pas trop puis
surtout moi je pense que les professeurs
sont vendeurs de tout ça c'est les
premières lignes les professeurs je vais
vous raconter une anecdote c'était en
maternelle à la fin de chaque année ou
de je parle à l'époque de cheval
trimestre ou des 5 années on fait un
petit un petit bilan de comment se situe
l'élève comment est-ce qu'on porte en
classe est-ce qu'il travaille bien
est-ce qu'il y a une compréhension et
tout ça voilà et c'est ma femme qui va
avoir la maîtresse voilà et la maîtresse
prend la feuille de Jeanne et là dit bah
écoutez Jeanne elle a du mal à elle a du
mal à le dire l'alphabet là Jeanne elle
a du mal à faire ça j'ai un aliment fait
j'allais elle a du malentendre
s'intégrer Jeanne elle est toute seule
tout ça donc une liste comme ça de
choses très très très négatives et ma
femme dit un moment mais écoutez je
m'excuse mais là vous êtes en train de
me citer des choses qui sont très
négatives pour jeunes mais est-ce que
vous pouvez me citer des choses qui sont
positives qu'est-ce qu'elle fait bien
John la maîtresse regarde
dans la mesure où cette maîtresse a su
dire ça à ma femme face à face je n'ose
imaginez ce que c'était en classe pour
jeune attention je ne dis pas que la
maîtresse faisait du harcèlement avec ma
fille je dis pas ça tout ce que je veux
dire c'est que on a toujours eu une
incompréhension que ma fille partait à
l'école en pleurant elle était contente
de revenir et elle partait toujours
toujours toujours en pleurant je pense
que tout ça fait que Jeanne a eu très
très peu de confiance en elle je pense
que s'il y a l'été à l'origine
introvertie ça accentué ça et ben
c'était ça ça pourrait être une proie
aucun professeur ne souhaite évidemment
blesser un élève ou être la cause d'un
éventuel harcèlement ça c'est évident en
revanche on nous sommes tous des êtres
humains imparfaits et blesser un élève
peut arriver dans tous les cas même ici
la vraie chose qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est que si ça arrive et ben le pardon
est tout à fait possible aussi
profhélène ça n'aurait pas en question
du tout l'autorité des professeurs parce
que justement on a cette confiance qui
est construite par les enseignants avec
les élèves depuis leur arrivée à l'école
de là on a arrêté au plus possible le
périscolaire à la continuer son CO2
là-bas et à partir de du CM1 on l'a mis
dans une école privée ça se passe bien
mais toujours une jeune fille qui était
qui était seul qui était qui jouait
toujours toute seule et quelqu'un qui
avait un manque d'urgence en soi
finalement qui devait se dire bah
finalement j'arrive pas à me faire des
amis donc c'est c'est normal mais c'est
pas grave donc sachant que Jeanne était
déjà en difficulté on s'est dit bah il y
a une école qui ouvre à l'affaire
l'école Clovis et est arrivé ici en
début de 5e et ben écoutez ça a été une
métamorphose dans la mesure où il
faisait confiance dans le mesure on lui
a dit que finalement c'était quelqu'un
qui était c'était une vraie personne une
belle personne je pense que Jeanne
c'était un petit peu la l'étincelle
qu'il fallait qu'il fallait allumer et
puis ben tout de suite assez enflammé
elle s'est enflammée dans la mesure où
elle a pris confiance en elle et puis
elle s'est fait d'amis et et Jeanne
c'est quelqu'un qui est très sociable et
sa sociabilité elle s'est révélée au
grand jour finalement tout le monde a sa
place le cadre apaisé ça fait partie
d'un fondamental de notre fonctionnement
on redonne confiance aux enfants à tous
les enfants parce qu'ils font parce
qu'ils sont parce qu'ils réussissent et
pas uniquement de matière de manière
académique cette confiance adulte en
forme elle s'acquiert par le fait que
nos professeurs sont professeurs
éducateurs ça veut dire qu'ils passent
des moments avec les enfants ils
partagent des moments avec les enfants
du déjeuner de la cour de récréation des
matchs de foot il y a des soirées
d'organisées par les professeurs des
soirées pizza film des soirées jeux de
société vraiment le professeur vit des
moments éducatifs gratuits avec ses
enfants avec ses élèves les professeurs
vous voient tous les élèves les
respectent profondément évidemment ça
c'est un des outils c'est l'exemplarité
des enseignants vis-à-vis des élèves le
professeur estime chacun de la classe
naturellement chacun estimable une des
clés de lutte contre le harcèlement
c'est vraiment l'intervention
automatique et immédiate de l'école dès
le moindre problème dès le moindre
dispute et ensuite c'est tout ce travail
de vie de classe où on discute des
problèmes on apprend à s'écouter on
apprend à régler les problèmes on
apprend à se demander pardon mais très
concrètement comment on demande pardon
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut demander
pardon qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire quand
on nous demande pardon etc etc et les
élèves discutent entre eux en trouvant
leur solution à eux on a mis par exemple
en place la roue des pardons quand il y
a une dispute les élèves peuvent y aller
seul sans adulte devant cette roue du
pardon pour décider ensemble comment
est-ce qu'ils vont se réconcilier est-ce
que la personne qui a été offensée
est-ce qu'elle va vouloir juste qu'on se
serre la main qu'on joue ensemble à la
récré qu'on déjeune ensemble demain
avoir un beau dessin quand c'est des
petites classes des choses comme ça et
c'est eux qui choisissent ensemble ok
ben je te pardonne mais comme comme j'ai
été un peu blessé ben voilà un dessin ça
me ferait plaisir l'autre fait un dessin
c'est terminé on apprend aussi que
blesser quelqu'un peut arriver sans que
ce soit définitif vous avez il y a une
chose qui se passe ici c'est la première
fois que je vois ça tous les élèves ils
sont valorisés pas forcément
naturellement sur un plan scolaire mais
ils sont aussi valorisés sur toutes les
petites choses de la vie ça veut dire
que si jamais il va y avoir une
embrouille avec deux élèves et qu'un
autre élève va essayer de comprendre un
peu ce qui se passe il valoriser si
jamais il voit qu'il y ait des papiers
dans la cour et puis qui vont ramasser
spontanément le papier il va de
valoriser et une autre directeur tous
les vendredis il dit une chose qui moi
qui moi me trouve vraiment c'est dire
croyez en vous et soyez des héros et ça
veut tout dire il y a pas que le resto
scolaire vous êtes fort bien croyez en
vous bien sûr vous êtes capable de faire
ça bien sûr vous êtes capable de
surmonter ça bien sûr vous êtes capable
d'aider cette personne là bien sûr vous
êtes capable si les autres peuvent le
faire et si on n'arrête pas de me le
dire et ben forcément je ne se dit ben
oui je suis capable de le faire ici nous
avons choisi pour lutter contre le
harcèlement notamment le port de
l'uniforme pour deux raisons la première
c'est qu'évidemment il y a plus de
concurrence des marques il y a plus la
concurrence de la mode on est tous
habillé pareil mais il y a aussi
le sentiment d'appartenance au groupe
évidemment que des élèves peuvent être
mis à l'écart évidemment que mais le
fait d'être habillé pareil même si on
est à l'écart inconsciemment on
appartient quand même au groupe c'est
comme une équipe de foot c'est comme
c'est souvent l'exemple que je prends
auprès des nous sommes une équipe de
foot nous sommes une équipe tout court
pour les adolescents la façon de
s'habiller c'est on est dans une société
où l'image compte de plus en plus avec
les réseaux sociaux avec l'arrivée des
filtres etc l'image c'est primordial là
c'est réglé et le téléphone donc nous
nous faisons déposer les téléphones aux
enfants tous les matins j'accueille les
élèves au portail ils mettent dans une
petite boîte leur téléphone pour la
journée et la récupèrent en sortant le
soir ça évite déjà tous les toutes les
communications pendant le temps scolaire
ça évite les films de filmer un élève
pour le poster pour se moquer etc de 8 à
17 ils ont plus cette pression du
téléphone et du réseau alors évidemment
il le retrouve en partant et à la maison
le problème reste le même on avait une
fille en cinquième qui est arrivé chez
nous en 6e il y a quelques années elle
était arrivée pour du harcèlement les
parents habitaient à quasiment trois
quarts d'heure de route mais ils avaient
fait le trajet parce que l'école d'à
côté vraiment leur fille était harcelées
elle arrive à l'école changement presque
immédiat leur fille se remet à sourire
elle passe des bonnes soirées en famille
etc etc arriver en 5ème elle reprend des
attitudes qu'elle avait quand elle
faisait harceler elle parle plus elle
monte dans sa chambre et pleure
facilement et s'énerve elle répond à ses
parents les parents comprennent pas et
instinctivement se disent elle est
harcelée au cours Clovis donc elle
m'appelle il me disent tout ça donc je
prends je prends évidemment en compte ce
numéro monté même si ça m'étonnait
énormément parce que je la vois à
l'école elle a des amis elle est pas
mise de côté du tout et donc on creuse
on creuse et la maman se rend compte que
sur son téléphone elle appartient à un
groupe d'anciens élèves de son ancienne
école et qu'elle se refaire harceler les
bras m'en sont tombés parce que la maman
était complètement démunie et elle me
dit mais qu'est-ce que je peux faire
monsieur Chanu et pas une seconde est
venu à l'idée de cette maman qui était
vraiment une belle maman une bonne maman
qui aimait ses filles qui travaillait
beaucoup
pas une seconde elle s'est dit je vais
je vais enlever le téléphone j'enlève le
téléphone c'était terminé c'était
terminé ça se passait bien à l'école ça
se passe bien en famille il y avait plus
de problème donc vraiment le les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui aggrave le phénomène
de harcèlement dans les dans les dans
les sociétés scolaires l'enfant n'est
plus coupé des autres plus jamais ça
veut dire que il est présent de 8h à 17h
à l'école de 17h à minuit il est encore
avec ses copains sur le téléphone et ça
moi profondément je pense que c'est un
drame pour les jeunes adolescents on
parle beaucoup de charge mentale
aujourd'hui imaginons la charge mentale
d'un élève qui doit assumer sa
représentation sociale jusqu'à son
coucher et qui doit la réassumer dès
qu'il se réveille sur son téléphone
parce que ça commence à mon école on
imagine pas la fatigue la le stress que
ça peut engendrer et puis évidemment le
harcèlement du coup prend des
proportions bien plus grandes puisque
puisqu'il continue même quand vous êtes
dans votre lit en fait on a mis en place
aussi depuis quelques années un vrai
travail avec les familles sur ça de
prévention on fait venir des
intervenants qui viennent former les
profs et les familles c'est ce qu'on
appelle les cafés des parents la
dernière fois on a fait intervenir à
Monsieur d'une association qui qui
travaillent sur ça pour apprendre par an
à mettre un contrôle parental pour voir
contrôler les applications téléchargées
sur quel réseau sont leurs enfants parce
que légalement il y a des limites d'âge
dans les réseaux alors c'est évidemment
très théorique mais n'empêche qu'il y a
la loi interdit l'accès au réseau en
dessous d'un certain âge donc c'est
aussi aider les parents à faire
appliquer la loi et puis leur volonté il
y a beaucoup de parents qui sont qui
sont dépassés malgré eux et puis dans
dans notre fonctionnement vraiment
chaque élève fait partie d'une équipe
d'élèves qui qui dépasse les limites de
la classe et donc chaque élève des
jeunes en équipe donc aucun élève des
jeunes tout seul aucun élève ne fait un
jeu organisé par l'école tout seul ce
fonctionnement là permet que tout le
monde ait des amis les amitiés choisis
et des amitiés non choisi ce
fonctionnement par équipe ça permet
aussi aux élèves de s'ouvrir vers des
élèves vers qui il serait pas forcément
allés naturellement Jeanne aujourd'hui
et chef d'équipe elle est responsable de
cinq élèves filles et c'est une super
chef très épanouie très souriante qui
prend soin de ses filles qui est
responsable Jean ça a été une personne
qui était au départ introverti et
maintenant c'est une fille qui est qui
est joyeuse qui a des amis qui vit sa
vie comme elle doit vivre sa vie qui a
des activités qui fait du violon qui
fait du théâtre qui s'éclate qui est
bienveillante d'ailleurs elle va en
faire son métier parce que elle va elle
va suivre une formation après son cours
de troisième elle va rentrer dans une
école de formation professionnelle ou
elle va faire une formation de soins à
la personne et c'est quelqu'un qui est
naturellement bienveillante
[Musique]